jetzt wieder in die usa ganz in den
westen der usa nämlich dorthin wo die
hitze besonders groß ist ganz in die
nähe von las vegas in die stadt des
glücksspiels und auch in die stadt in
der die mafia aktiv war jahrzehntelang
das große geld dort gerochen hat und wo
die mafia ihre geheimnisse bewahrt hat
bis heute jetzt kommen jahrzehnte alte
geheimnisse dort an diesem see ans licht
opfer der mafia die für immer als
verschollen galten die tauchen nämlich
plötzlich wieder auf schuld der
klimawandel
die sonne brennt unbarmherzig heiß vom
himmel 40 grad außentemperatur sind
keine seltenheit mit dramatischen folgen
der lag mit trocknet aus und gibt seine
dunklen geheimnisse preis hier sieht man
wie der wasserspiegel zurückgegangen ist
wie dramatisch dieser vorfall war wenn
man sich ansieht hier auf diese
schotterstraße die vor einigen jahren
noch unter wasser gestanden ist sieht
man ein schild wo der wasserpegel war im
jahr
2018 man sieht ist dort hinten ungefähr
50 meter entfernt und wenn man jetzt
hier weiter schwenkt sieht man den
wasserspiegel im jahr 2021 also in drei
jahren hat sich ungefähr dieser see um
eine strecke von 50 metern verkleinert
allerdings jetzt wird es noch
dramatischer denn von hier
2021 bis dieses jahr 2022 zieht man in
der ferne wie beides jetzt zum fluss ist
der pegel feld und zum vorschein kommen
leichen ermordet einbetoniert und im see
versenkt zu einer zeit in der noch
keiner an den klimawandel dachte und der
tiefe stausee ein sicheres versteck war
für die mordopfer der mafia denn der lag
mit liegt nur wenige kilometer vor den
toren las vegas dem glücksspiel eldorado
der vereinigten staaten wer sich in las
vegas mit den falschen leuten einlässt
für den endet das glücksspiel häufig
hier
[Musik]
1936 in betrieb genommen das nasse grab
der mafia opfer denn die schillernde
zocker metropole in der wüste nevadas
war bis mitte der 80er jahre fest in der
hand des organisierten verbrechen und
wer hier nicht zahlt zahlten mit seinem
leben auch deshalb gehen die behörden
und anwohner dagegen davon aus dass sich
die leichenfunde wie aus den vergangenen
wochen noch häufen werden
[Musik]
ja das thema schlechthin hier auf jeden
fall das stadtgespräch und jeder hat
seine eigene spekulation und so weiter
sie haben herausgefunden dass ein
mordopfer war vielleicht die mafia wer
weiß die haben das opfer da drüben auf
der anderen seite der marina gefunden
zwischen dem steg und der laderampe also
mich hat das nicht wirklich überrascht
ich bin schon mein ganzes leben hier und
wissen sie der see der so viele
geheimnisse und auch in zukunft werden
wir bestimmt hier und da immer wieder
was finden im auftrag der clans
beseitigen männer wie toni spiel otro
unliebsame opfer auf erbarmungslose
weise spiel otto berüchtigte
auftragskiller der 70er jahre war
nachweislich in mehr als 20 mafia morde
verwickelt in martin scorseses
hollywood-klassiker casino wird er von
joe pesci verkörpert sein markenzeichen
erschoss seinen opfern mit einer
kleinkaliberpistole samt aufgeschraubten
schalldämpfer in den kopf genau so
vermuten experten erging es auch dem
erst vor kurzem an den sich ständig neu
formierenden ufern des sees gefundenen
opfer
man geht davon aus dass es sich bei dem
man im fass um johny papas einen casino
manager aus chicago handelt er geriet
ins visier der mafia kurz bevor er
verschwand soll er seiner frau gesagt
haben dass er sich mit einem käufer
seines bootes am laid treffen wolle
eine falle
seine leiche blieb verschollen bis heute
und mit jedem zentimeter den der pegel
des late feld droht ein neues kapitel
von las vegas dreckiger vergangenheit
aufgeschlagen zu werden
[Musik]